welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and with the Loki series ending in
a finale that elevates Loki to a true
God status did Marvel Studios actually
push the release of the series to give
themselves a possible offramp from Kang
and instead shift toward Dr Doom as the
new Big Bad of the Multiverse Saga in
this video I'm going to break down the
breaking news we've gotten from
interviews with the lowkey producers and
from Marvel exec with deadline and a
report from our colleague Joanna
Robinson co-author of the MCU reign of
Marvel Studios book about a possible
shift in Avengers 5 from K to Doom by
the way there are still some seats left
for our live show in Los Angeles on
Thursday it's getting hotter and hotter
every day we have special guests some
fun bits we have never been able to do
on YouTube and a public apology from me
over my Reacher theories from Loki this
season okay in an article from deadline
today Marvel exec Kevin Wright who was
the rep from Marvel Studios Brain Trust
assigned to the Loki series he confirmed
that the plan was to use this season of
Loki and its themes to align the overall
plan for the Multiverse Saga moving
forward he said quote there is going to
be a stronger emphasis trying to make
make sure everyone is working from the
same sheets the same script I think that
is partially trying to get these writers
on the Loki side who had been living in
this world to maybe hopefully populate
into other projects so that they can
help with that or just better
conversations Among The Producers
internally we've told almost 12 hours of
Loki story with the hope that they would
come to us a little bit and go hey does
this align with what you've been doing
it will probably help us out
tremendously so this would make it seem
like headwriter Eric Martin is going to
play a very Hands-On role with every
Multiverse Saga story that's going to be
told from here forward including maybe
some elements of Deadpool 3 but the
Fantastic 4 film and Avengers 5 and 6
this article also included a
confirmation that Loki is the god of
stories deadline used those words but
they only use that term after getting
confirmation from headwriter Eric Martin
and from Kevin Wright when you're
writing an article as a journalist you
include direct quotes but he also
include paraphrases and God of stories
would have been confirmed by Eric Martin
and from Kevin Wright when they were
being interviewed for this article Eric
Martin said going into season 2 it felt
like an opportunity to bring gravity to
the series to step up a level because we
marched up to the line and got to The
Man Behind the curtain and the stakes
got extremely high at the end of the
season let's keep climbing let's keep
building that the idea was always Loki
would finally get his throne when it was
the last thing he wanted and like Atlas
he's burdened with this purpose and his
purpose is holding all of time together
he has replaced the loom he's become so
powerful that he alone can hold time
together deadlines said that even in the
midst of season 1 the creative team knew
that they wanted season 2 to take Loki
from a lowercase G God to a capital G
God as Martin put it and then Martin
went on to say then the work goes into
like how do you achieve that everything
goes back to the fight in the Citadel at
the end of season 1 which obviously we
wanted to end up there at the end of
season 2 but looming over season 2 is a
question of like well who was correct
Loki or syi so the question became about
exploring that what is the new reality
that they face what happens when you
remove the power structure and now there
is kind of nothing moreing this so with
Loki becoming a guide in full control of
the eil time tree that in effect
downgrades the importance of Kang in the
MCU because Loki directly challenged the
authority of he remains in his system of
timeline management replacing a need for
Kang in the MCU and we even got a hint
to that with this reference to all the
loose kangs that have now been Unleashed
and as you may or may not know my
variants are already out there we'll
find them there's too many I won't stop
doesn't matter never sto me before I
know champ he calls him champ it's
almost like he remains his acknowledging
even if this line wasn't originally
intended this way when they originally
wrote it but acknowledging that another
Multiverse Mastermind can rival his
power when you have a Loki this powerful
do you really even need a Kang the final
minutes showed a case File recapping the
events of anman the wasan Mania that
they said was pretty much handled as if
it was like done we have been trying to
make this out actually Adam burns on
Twitter made out that this Kang's
variant number is K 8910 there was a
Kang from Earth 8910 in the Excalibur
number 14 in 1989 I don't know if it's
connected but just by presenting this
case File in the lines we heard at Mobay
just made it sound like that case File
is closed our merch inspired by Loki
season 2 keeps branching out from from
the sacred timeline my friends we got
shirts inspired by Miss minutes and our
favorite repairs and advancements
employee OB we've got a gorgeous mobus
jet ski design that makes you wish you
could get pruned away to wherever those
guys are at if you order the TVA
handbook shirt I can't be promise it
will be dropped into your open window
like Rin slayer at Victor timely's
Workshop that's completely up to your
relationship with your local delivery
driver and if you want to snag a
Marvel's tea we've got you covered there
too on my flerkens out there grabbing a
tea from nerd Riot is a great great way
to support new rock stars to get some
Loki merch of your very own either click
the link in the description or head on
over to nerd rot. shop many are seeing
the way this season Loki ended to be a
possible out for Marvel Studios in case
they want to move away as Kang as such
an important character for their future
plans so Joanna Robinson who as the
author of the best piece of non-fiction
about Marvel Studios history is really
in my opinion the most reliable
journalist with the best sources she
said in the house of our deep died
podcast into the Loki season 2 finale
these words about what's going going on
I actually heard from someone recently I
was asking about the screenwriter Jeff
lovess who wrote quantam Mania was
supposed to write King Dynasty and then
it was sort of like came out that maybe
he was no longer anyway it's confirm
like I got I had it confirmed to me he's
no longer working for Marvel and that I
asked the person why and they said the
reason why was that like his stuff you
know he was all wrapped up in this King
story line and that they are likely
going to moving away from that so no
official announcement that Avengers
colon King Dynasty will now be called
Doom's dystopia or whatever like we
don't know like exactly what they're
going to do to be clear but I think that
this just gives them perfect opportunity
to just be done they want to be whoa so
Joanna definitely has the highest
credibility of anyone I know talking
about Marvel and the way these
executives are actually plotting things
out I don't think she would have said
this if there wasn't some movement
actually happening at the studio right
now so with Marvel delaying to 2025 all
of next year's MCU films aside from
Deadpool 3 it just seems like the studio
is giving themselves some time to
reconfigure things there was that
variety report last week that said
Marvel was among many options
considering a pivot from Kang to Dr Doom
but that article also exaggerated how
big of a role Kang would play in the
finale of Loki so I don't know how much
we could trust that article but Jonathan
Major's domestic violence trial is now
set to take place on November 29th he
did lose his bid to have the case
dismissed it's worth noting that Dr Doom
was really the central antagonist for
the Jonathan Hickman run of the time
Runs Out storyline that led to the 2015
Secret Wars crossover that based on Reed
Richard's dialogue in Multiverse of
match it seems to be the primary
storyline that the studio is adapting
for the Multiverse Saga if they were to
Pivot back to Doom in some ways it would
be more in line with what the comics
have already done and yes there was that
little moment in the Loki finale in
which M has told Loki about a kid by the
Black Sea who would have grown up to
kill 5,000 people which geographically
could be the country of laberia and a
young Victor Von Doom I don't know about
that Marvel Studios is expected to
announce its fantastic Ford lineup in
the coming weeks and that might include
a big announcement about a new actor to
play Dr Doom would a switched to Dr
Doom's Scuttle all the work Marvel
Studios has done for Kang already well
aside from Loki and quantam media how
involved has Kang really been with the
MCU I mean who knows Marvel could just
continue to suggest that conflicts
between kangs and Loki just made a big
mess of things throughout the Multiverse
Saga and someone else could step in to
clean up that mess that someone could be
Victor Von Doom imagine someone like Dr
Doom could exploit and take advantage of
all of this chaos because he would be
capable of seeing a vision and an
opportun that those in the trenches of
the Multiverse War could not see and
that Vision could be battle World a vast
conflict between Avengers and X-Men and
spider people and Marvel villains to
decide who belongs in the 616 Universe
moving forward I want to know from you
who do you want to be the big bad of the
Multiverse Saga Doom or Kang please
support us with one of these OB inspired
we're all going to die shirts at nerd
rot. shop you can follow me on all
socials at eaos subscribe to the three
channels of the new rockstars Network
thanks for watching I'll see you next
time
bye
[Music]
n